neuf secondes,
c'est ce que je vais te donner pour décider de ton
sort
[Musique]
Roberto, dis-moi qu'est-ce que tu as fait à
la maison, au
gouvernement, je suis à la retraite à cause de
ces gens, je commence à comprendre les
vraies personnes, ils te voient comme l'un des nôtres
maintenant
crois que c'est là que je suis censé être
cela arrive dans de nombreux récits la mafia
ils aiment le cancer pas de remède
quoi que toi et tes amis faites-le
ailleurs vous apprenez l'anglais Je
prépare
c'est qu'un Timex non c'est un hamburger
tu sembles  comme un homme qui comprend
la violence
[Musique]
J'aime cet endroit, tu ne peux pas m'enlever ça
Je peux prendre tout ce que je veux, mon
amour, la
police a trouvé plusieurs cadavres dans
cette ferme en Sicile, est-ce que tu le tues
[Musique]
étranger
[  Applaudissements]
[Musique]